Donald Trump did deliver what I believe we
can safely call his final address as president
of the United States yesterday.
It's basically an unrecognizable person.
This is not a Trump we have ever seen before.
It's not like Trump has been this person we
saw yesterday for the last four years, but
was pretending to be somebody else.
I believe that the Trump we saw yesterday
is a fake Trump.
It is a desperate Trump.
And Trump's speech yesterday is a desperate
plea for mercy.
Trump is isolated, furious, abandoned by many
Republicans, banned from a number of social
media accounts.
And he sat in the Oval Office yesterday and
recorded what he hopes is a speech that will
save him, that will take the pressure off
in terms of a possible impeachment conviction
in the Senate.
He is attempting to dial down the possibility
of future investigations into his endless
wrongdoing.
Let's take a look at it.
My fellow Americans, I want to speak to you
tonight about the troubling events of the
past week.
As I have said, the incursion of the U.S.
Capitol struck at the very heart of our republic.
It angered and appalled millions of Americans
across the political spectrum.
I want to be very clear, I unequivocally condemn
the violence that we saw last week, violence
and vandalism have absolutely no place in
our country and no place in our movement.
Making America great again has always been
about defending the rule of law.
So a unifying and empathetic Trump.
Right.
Give me a break, guys.
No one who has been paying attention for the
last really now five plus years is falling
for this.
This is Trump having a speech on a prompter
shoved in front of him and being told this
is what you need to say to maybe save yourself
from some of what is unlike what is likely
to be coming.
And, of course, Trump now the unifier around
the riots he caused through his two months
of election lies and a speech saying, let's
go to the Capitol right now.
Now, of course, the Magga movement has never
been about defending the rule of law.
They say that.
But even before being president, Trump would
tell his supporters that if they are rough
with protesters at his rallies and they get
arrested and charged, he'll pay their legal
fees.
And now, as we'll find out on the bonus show
today, Trump doesn't pay anybody's legal fees.
He's not even paying his own.
But we'll get to that later.
Let's get to more of yesterday's bizarre statement
from Trump.
Mob violence goes against everything I believe
in and everything our movement stands for.
No true supporter of mine could ever endorse
political violence.
No true supporter of mine could ever disrespect
law enforcement or our great American flag.
No true supporter of mine could ever threaten
or harass their fellow Americans.
If you do any of these things, you are not
supporting our movement.
You're attacking it and you are attacking
our country.
We can not tolerate it.
Tragically, over the course of the past year,
made so difficult because of covid-19, Trump
caused the mob violence.
His supporters led a mob.
It's sort of a no true Scotsman situation.
If anyone rioted, then by definition they
couldn't have been my supporters.
Well, sir, they had Trump hats and Trump shirts
and Trump flags when they broke in and when
they gave interviews, they said they were
for Trump.
And when they posted to social media, they
said they were for Trump.
Yeah, but they weren't true supporters of
mine.
Indefeasible right.
It's a closed loop.
You can't you can't break it, as we talked
about last week.
Trump also, by the way, mentioned covid-19
there.
Now, Trump, of course, has disastrously mishandled
the virus.
So everything about this speech is just fantasy
world Looney Tunes.
Here's another uniting message from this new
Trump.
Whether you are on the right or on the left,
a Democrat or a Republican, there is never
a justification for violence.
No excuses, no exceptions.
America is a nation of laws.
Those who engaged in the attacks last week
will be brought to justice.
Now, I am asking everyone who has ever believed
in our agenda to be thinking of ways to ease
tensions, calm tempers and help to promote
peace in our country.
Now, some people might hear Trump say everyone
will be brought to justice and they will react
by saying, wow, Trump's doing the right thing.
He's being tough on the rioters.
That really takes takes some strength.
Trump never cared about the rioters.
Here's what people have to understand.
When they were rioting, Trump was pleased.
Initially, we know he was liking it and he
liked how it delayed the electoral vote count.
He never cared about the rioters as people.
He never cared about the rioters as his voters
or supporters.
It just was useful to his political goals.
Then Trump noticed that the rioters looked
low class.
That's these are the reports.
We got multiple reports about that Trump still
didn't care about them as people.
He just cared about how they made him look
and low class rioters made Trump look bad.
Remember, Trump has spent his entire life
trying to stay away from people like most
of his supporters, that his golf clubs and
at his high rise apartments and then the rioters.
Now we're getting arrested.
And it led to Trump's impeachment.
So Trump denounces them and says, they're
not my true supporters and they're going to
be persecuted, prosecuted to the fullest extent
of the law.
He's not abandoning anyone in so far as he
was never actually with them.
They were always merely political tools.
And now he's using this to try to get points
for lowering the temperature.
But it's much too late to matter.
Let's watch a little bit more.
Donald Trump saying don't do any more riots,
please.
There has been reporting that additional demonstrations
are being.
Planned in the coming days, both here in Washington
and across the country.
I have been briefed by the U.S. Secret Service
on the potential threats every American deserves
to have their voice heard in a respectful
and peaceful way.
That is your First Amendment right.
But I cannot emphasize that there must be
no violence, no lawbreaking and no vandalism
of any kind.
Everyone must follow our laws and obey the
instructions of law enforcement.
I have directed federal agencies to use all
necessary resources to maintain order in Washington,
D.C.
We are bringing in thousands of National Guard
members to secure the city and ensure that
a transition can occur safely and without
incident.
So there it is.
Trump sending a message.
No more riots.
Now, Trump can't get out of this without doing
some of his typical routines.
So here Trump goes after social media platforms
for banning him as assaults on free speech.
I also want to say a few words about the unprecedented
assault on free speech we have seen in recent
days.
These are tense and difficult times.
The efforts to censor, cancel and blacklist
our fellow citizens are wrong and they are
dangerous.
What is needed now is for us to listen to
one another, not to silence one another.
All of us can choose by our actions to rise
above the rancor and find common ground and
shared purpose.
We must focus on advancing the interests of
the whole nation, delivering the miracle vaccines,
defeating the pandemic, rebuilding the economy,
protecting our national security and upholding
the rule of law.
Now, of course, the social media stuff is
not a free speech issue.
I'm not going to get into that again.
We've gone over that ad nauseum.
And, of course, this Donald Trump, we've never
seen this Trump because he doesn't exist.
This isn't the real Trump.
The real guy is the guy.
He has plainly been in public, which matches
the guy.
He's plainly been in private.
That's the real Trump.
The five minute Trump we saw yesterday is
just a pathetic, desperate attempt to save
himself and get some mercy so that Republicans,
when the impeachment trial starts, can say,
listen, Trump lowered the temperature, he
dialed it down.
We're not going to vote to convict.
That's the goal.
And one more thing.
If this would have been Trump all along, it
would have been fake, but he would have gotten
reelected if with the virus, Trump had done
that and said this is a tough time.
Let's listen to the doctors.
No mass anti mass protest.
Just listen to the doctors.
Way fewer people would have died and Trump
would have sailed to reelection.
There would have been no riot and Trump would
be getting another four years, too little
too late from fake Trump.
Let me know your reaction.
I'm on Twitter at
David Pakman,